our families actually did not count on this
and that our men
were also not mentally and physically prepared for this
situation; they are not military, they are civilian
professions, and in connection with this we are talking about the
need to return them from the
front, we are interested in having them
cancel  in general, it
was impossible to mobilize civilians and it was impossible for the second three
waves of mobilization in principle, so
we also advocate that, in general, if a
contract soldier signs a contract for a year, then
after a year he should have the voluntary
right to either continue it or go
home because with contract soldiers  They also
act unfairly in the same way as with those who were
mobilized indefinitely, they are there.
This is wrong, this is
contrary to the Constitution of the Russian
Federation. I wanted to
lay
flowers to give a tribute to the memory of the
dead. Of course, I would like for those who were
mobilized to start returning
home. I have a large family, my husband
is there, so of course he is
missing. I think  that this
rather allows me to feel that I am doing
at least something, that is, I don’t think about my
situation,
but for now I hope that they
won’t break me or beat me up for this right now. I want to be
here and show, as it were, my attitude
to
what is happening